so hello everyone today I'm gonna talk
about bottlenecks estimation and privacy
this work was done together with how
with lots of people the results that I'm
gonna present here or a collection of
results that were done together with
amazing collaborators how long'd Isabeau
sang-soo Mike Maria Maria Medard ken
Duffy Lolita Mario Diaz and Shahab as we
did so this is not a talk about
differential privacy please don't leave
the room I promise you're gonna learn
something interesting hopefully and I'm
going to start off talking about the
privacy setup that I'll be using today
it's something that we call the one-shot
release model we've seen this in
previous talks and I'm just going to
motivate it with an example before I go
to the outline of the talk okay so
assume that we have the following
setting we have a user and this user has
some data for example their TV show
ratings that they want to share with a
data creator okay why do what they want
to share that data because they want to
receive some utility from that data for
example recommendations of new TV shows
you watch at the same time this user has
something that they want to keep secret
for example they want to keep secret the
fact if they're a Republican or a
Democrat well if the user sends the data
as is there gonna be received the best
utility from this data collector all
right the best recommendations but at
the same time there might be privacy
risk incurred through inference
inferences right the data collector
might look at the data and see that this
user likes to a Colbert show likes The
Daily Show doesn't like Fox and Friends
chances are they are a Democrat what can
the user do about that they can distort
the data right they can change the data
somehow before releasing it for example
distorting it through erasers removing
certain TV shows you know and release
that to the data collector in this case
there might have good utility I'm sorry
they might have good privacy you know
everyone likes lost everyone likes
friends everyone really loves Game of
Thrones but at the same time the quality
of the utility that they receive might
be a little bit worse right they might
receive a recommendation for a show
that's very popular but they're not very
interested in and the goal of this talk
is shown correct as you understand this
privacy utility
from what I call here an estimation
theoretic perspective and I'll make that
precise as I go along
okay so this is the outline I'm going to
start off with an overview of dealing
with this privacy utility trade-off from
an optimization for America this is
approach that you see in a lot of papers
in information theory okay and I'm going
to explain how this is related to
something that we call bottleneck
problems you might have heard for
example the information bottleneck then
I'm going to talk about the Chi square
as a privacy metric I am NOT making a
case to use Chi square as a privacy
metric I'm just going to show that when
you measure privacy in terms of Chi
square interesting things show up
fundamental things show up in terms of
the trade-off between privacy and
utility then present one convex
formulation for designing privacy serene
mappings I might go a little bit quickly
through this part of the talk if I don't
have time and go to the end of how can
you estimate some of these quantities in
practice okay so I'm going to start with
a brief overview on bottleneck problems
and data processing inequalities and how
it relates to privacy within this
one-shot really setting that I mentioned
so they make this a little bit more
precise this is a model that we'll be
looking at it's a toy example where we
have a private future s as for secret we
have data X and our engineering goal is
to understand what are the limits of
engine of designing this blue box here
at privacy of sharing mapping that will
randomize one sample insure this close
data white that you're going to give to
the interested party this interested
party will give you some utility right
because privacy without utility is
cryptography and at the same time it's
going to this interested party will try
to infer something about your private
feature and I'm good you make an
information theoretic assumption in the
stock and this information theoretic
assumption is that we know this
distribution here we're going to relax
this a little bit later but for now just
for the purpose of introducing these
metrics its role with that and consider
that this distribution is known so and
the NGO today of what I'm going to talk
about next if you understand the optimal
privacy utility trade-off and try to
design mappings that approach this limit
all right if you give me a privacy
metric and a utility metric what is the
optimal trade-off that you can achieve
so in this case in this scenario like
this hypothetical scenario where the
distributions are known you can do this
by formulating an optimization problem
right you can you confirm rate something
like this you're trying to design this
channel this randomized mapping in order
to minimize some privacy measures some
privacy risk subject to some utility
constraint I'm trying to assure that
this utility between x and y is above a
certain value however you may measure it
and today we're going to be trying to
understand for different values of
privacy measures and utility measures
what are the joint range of pairs of
privacy and utility that we can achieve
okay
across all possible privacy of string
mappings so we want to understand what
is the set of these achievable pairs for
a fixed distribution P of SX okay so
that's what we're doing so one possible
formulation for this and this was
introduced by folks by my I've looked at
this Lolita has looked at this and many
others in the literature you can for
example estimate privacy as mucha
information right you might want to
minimize the average number of bits
between that Y carries about s your
secret subject some distortion
constraint some square distortion for
example this is a nice formulation
because it's convex and you can actually
apply it to real-world data sets and see
how these mappings look like another
interesting formulation that was
presented by collaborators of mine is
something called a privacy funnel okay
so in the privacy funnel you're
measuring you're trying to minimize the
average number of bits the average
information that Y carries about s Y
were insuring that on average Y carries
a leaks at least three bits of
information about X and what I like
about the privacy funnel is because this
is just a specific instantiation of a
broader family of problems that I like
to call bottleneck problems and
bottleneck problems appear in many
places in information theory ok so if
you ask what is the joint range of pairs
between privacy the mutual information
between s and Y and utility the mooch
information between x and y you can plot
this in a graph right
here we have this Markov chain
relationship as XY we're trying to
understand the joint rate of you're
assuming that P of s X is fixed on the x
axis I have the moocher information
between x and y so on the x axis I have
something that's similar to utility and
on the y axis I have something that
looks like privacy so across all
possible Maps here this joint range
lives within this 45 degree below this
45 degree line within this blue region
because of the data processing
inequality right so the mooch
information between x and y is always
going to be greater than the moocher
information between s and y and the
truth is that the set of all achievable
pairs will live in a compact set that
looks like this okay so here on the top
axis I have the and the stop point is
simply when I make x equals y and on the
bottom is when y is independent of X and
everything else so the upper boundary of
this region is what is known as the
information bottleneck you might have
heard it it's back in vogue now in terms
of video networks and so on and the
lower boundary of this region is privacy
it's a privacy funnel they saw this
upper boundary this is at the heart of
many results in information theory for
example strong data processing
inequalities when you try to improve
upon your vanilla 45-degree line
inequality where you have a strong data
processing inequality misses there's a
well-known result in information theory
known as mrs. Gerber's lemma which is
using metric information theory which is
related to the through the
characteristics of this upper bound when
s and X are binary and there's a
beautiful paper I would argue somewhat
underappreciated paper by which and
housing and Viner from 1975 where they
say many things about the geometry of
this upper bound recently and I'm not
going to go into details and a paper at
I psyche last year we said we use the
same tools as which in house an
environment is privacy funnel then you
get the counterparts of mrs. grabbers
lemma we called it mr. Gruber's lemma
for you can fully characterize this
region when s and X is binary as well
but you can use the same tools from
information
the same with the tool from tools from
convex geometry channelized that so
another just to mention this another
thing that's interesting is the
derivative of this region right at the
around the origin the derivative of this
curve of this upper bound at the origin
is related to something called
contraction coefficients and contraction
coefficients are connected to strong
data process in equalities in this case
for KL divergence and what we're going
to be interested in in the context of
privacy as I mentioned is the lower
boundary here right because this lower
boundary gives you the privacy utility
trade-off in the context of much
information and I think kamala already
mentioned F divergence is a natural
question to ask here is why use much
information right why would we use much
information to analyze this trade-off we
could in principle if you're looking at
this restricted average case we could
use any F divergence instead of KL
divergence right and specifically we
will be looking at this so what I define
here is something called the information
you can call it that way it's basically
when you substitute the KL divergence
and the definition of much information
for some other F divergence and
specifically if you're good should be
focusing on Chi square divergence and
I'm going to be motivating over the next
slides why we're going to be looking at
Chi square divergence as a privacy and
utility metric alright and if you're not
familiar with Chi square divergence is
given by this expectation here it's just
like mucha information minus the log
yeah data processing a college yeah well
this is just a cartoon yeah so this is
just the correct neighborhood the actual
region vote the pen
even more refined yeah so how do you so
what what are the variables that control
wearing the region you are at so it
would be this as you change this mapping
this region you're gonna trace this
region as you change this mapping P of Y
given X oh I see so the only parameter
here is PSS yeah exactly P of s X is
fixed and as you change the mapping from
Y to X over all possible Y all over
channels you also change PS x yeah
exactly yeah exactly
but no so you can show that it you can
you I think the cardinality is call of X
plus yeah you can use your cathode or
e-business and do that for discrete
cases for continuous cases it's much
more difficult we have a paper on strong
data processing air quality so I have a
paper with urea and II hung for AB for
input constraint Gaussian channels then
you have to use much more heavy
machinery to analyze this but in general
yeah so we're going to be looking at any
other questions before I go on okay so
we're good should be looking at this
choosing chi-square divergence it's a
divergence that I like a lot and it's
just like much information but without
the log okay and just a word of caution
divergences and metrics and average
metrics in general do not necessarily
provide strong privacy guarantees
usually you can minimize these F
informations just by doing something
that looks like an erasure channel like
you're you're gonna have very little
information on average leakage on
average but every once in a while you're
gonna be sending your information in the
clear so I'm not claiming that this
should be the the metrics that you
should be using but what I'm trying to
convince you here is that studying
trade-offs within the setting can review
important facets of the privacy utility
trade-off okay so with that caveat in
mind move add and look at these
trade-offs in terms of Chi square
divergence the record should be looking
at Chi square
a privacy metric and chi-square
divergence is very very closely related
to M MSC okay true minimum mean square
estimating estimation and what I'm going
to do next is that I'm going to present
you three problems three different
problems and all of these problems have
the same answer and these answer and
these gives somewhat of an operational
meaning to chi-square divergence and
something that I call the principal
inertia components okay so we're going
to look at three problems with the same
answer the first problem is a problem of
maximizing correlation so assume that I
have a random variable X and you have a
random variable Y their joint
distributed according to P of X Y and by
the way you're just take a step back now
just look at the operational definition
of chi-square so assume that we have a
random pair I have a random variable X
you have a random variable Y these are
not necessarily could be anything
distributed over images or whatever and
our goal is to find functions that have
zero mean and unit variance of x and y I
I'm going to find a function f of X
you're gonna find a function G of Y so
that they're maximally correlated so
that they maximize this correlation if
you could solve this problem the
solution for this is something that's
known as the maximal correlation
coefficient and I'm going to define this
as square root of lambda one it's
something called the largest print
sperner's your component okay
so let's assume we find this solution we
call this maximizing functions f1 and g1
and we repeat the same problem right so
now we're finding functions new function
f that's 0 mean unit variance and then
correlated to the previous one same
thing for G solve that problem again we
get the square root of lambda Chu which
we call the second principal inertia
component and we can put that as a
constraint again get the third singular
value the third prints furniture
component and so forth so these
functions that I get as I proceed
variational e in this way is something
that I'm going to call the principal
functions between x and y this is useful
in something thats related to
representation learning which should be
talking about this all the way at the
end of the talk and these singular
values here or what I call difference
proneural components so that's the first
problem these principal functions and
these quantities also appear as a
solution of a second problem
is a problem of MMSE estimation you know
so let's go so let me present this so
that's the question that you're asking
is which functions of a hidden variable
can be estimated with the smallest mean
squared error so I have X right and I
observe light and the question that I
ask is what is the function of X the
real valued function of X that has zero
mean and unit variance to avoid trivial
solutions that I can most reliable
reliably estimate that I can reconstruct
with the smallest mean square error
given an observation of life if you were
to solve this this function is exactly
the principal function from the previous
case it's F 1 and the value of the MMSE
is 1 minus lambda 1 or the square of the
maximum correlation here now you repeat
this problem again and say like well
what is another function that's
uncorrelated with my previous function
that I can reconstruct with the smallest
mean squared error so I get 1 minus the
second largest principal inertia
component and the solution is actually
as you proceed like that you get the the
remaining principal functions if you if
you squint at this and look at it from a
distance you can already start seeing
that this might be useful for privacy
right because as you proceed through
this decomposition you end up with a
basis right the set of our solving all
functions for the space of finite
variance functions of X okay and you end
up with a singular value that tells you
how well you can reconstruct any one of
these functions these are nonlinear
functions this is a just a basis for the
L true space so you're gonna have a
finite number of them if this if your
distribution is over a finite alphabet
you might have an infinite number of
them but then since this is a basis if
you're giving any function of X I can
decompose it in terms of this basis it's
a basis that's the definition right and
then it gives me a very easy way to
decompose not only the variance of F but
also the minimum mean square error of
estimating one of these functions right
so if I can write one of any function I
can write any function in terms of a
linear company
of this basis functions and then the MMS
here you can really easily write that
just in terms of a Phi square times 1
minus the principle inertia component
now this is why Chi square it's
interesting Chi square is interesting
because it's the sum of all these P ICS
okay so you can see that the Chi square
is exactly the sum of all these
principal components
so if Chi square is very very small you
have something that some other kinship
privacy right what that means is that
there is no non-trivial function of X
that you can reliably estimate from Y
because all these values will be very
small and the MMSE will be very large
and if this is if this Chi square is
high do you have something that seems
like utility right that it means that
there may be functions of X that you can
reliably estimate given Y and we're
going to explore this a little bit later
there is no privacy yes but you can
already start getting a few of how this
would map to privacy because what we're
going to show is that when you're
designing these mappings you want to
somehow
align your mapping such as only certain
functions can be estimated while others
cannot exactly exactly so that's where
we're going with that
well yeah you could you might be able to
map it that way absolutely I mean I
would still guess these chefs have to be
somewhere the fine space that cannot be
some arbitrary it's a producing Conan
here it is yes yes we can yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna put that question on hold
because I I don't fully understand the
connection between the two but there's
definitely a connection and he's this
guy who does design cases when we look
at he can look at anything and make an
actual tooth out of it so and I think
should provide further evidence that
this is connected to that this is the
third interpretation right so we looked
at the principal components in terms of
maximizing causation looked at it in
terms of minimizing mean squared error
and what's really the machinery that's
behind this is because what we're doing
is nothing more than looking at the
spectrum of the conditional expectation
operator so if you give me the space of
finite variance functions of Y and the
space of finite variance of functions of
X I can define the conditional
expectation operator it's just a linear
operator the maps of function here at
your map at your function and X by
taking conditional expectation and
senora operator we can diagonalize it
right we can look at it's singular
values we use this in fairness actually
like if you were to the talk you look at
the talk yesterday and we talked about
local perturbations of probability
measures this is what guides the
geometry of those local perturbations
and yeah and that's what I'm gonna say
about that so for the math aficionados
in the room where we're looking at it's
nothing more than the spectrum of the
conditional expectation operator how on
earth would you compute these prints for
inertia components right if I gave you a
distribution well if your distribution
is discrete and finite right so if it's
so if it's over a finite alphabet you
can build a matrix that looks like this
then without loss of generality I just
assume that things are distributed from
one shoe you and one shoe V I can build
a matrix whose entries or the jaw the
joint distribution divided by the square
root of the product of the marginals
take the singular value decomposition of
this matrix and the singular values are
exactly the be prince furniture
components square root of the principal
components
and up to a regularization term the left
and the right singular vectors
correspond through the principal
functions there are there is a
statistical method called correspondence
analysis that if you give me a data set
they try to build a contingency table
and normalize it exactly like that in
order to estimate to these principal
functions and I will have more to say
about that towards the end of the talk
this is almost like a nonlinear CCA then
you might we would even show that you
know like in the limit your function
classes are in analysis so and and
here's an equation that you might find
interesting maybe many of you haven't
seen it before you can think about this
principal components F is giving you a
fine grain decomposition of the Joint
Distribution so in the discrete case if
you give me a distribution of P of X Y I
can decompose it in this form where this
is independence right this is just your
if your if you had a dis independent
distribution and the coupling between x
and y can be given in terms of the p ICS
and these principal functions okay so
you can do this for for for many
distributions I was not the one that
proposed this like this has been studied
in many different places in the
information theory mathematical
statistics and probability theory
literature then all the way back to
Hirschfeld and give a line sir Manav and
rainy in terms of maximizing correlation
whitson housing has a also a beautiful
paper studying he appears many times in
this talk but studying maximum this in
the context of maximizing correlation
and strong data processing inequality
also alien galaxies and many others I
also want to mention the very exciting
work that's happening at MIT by Zhang
Jiang Gregg Bernal and his team they're
trying to use these they are using these
principal functions to understand things
like transfer learning and so on some
really cool stuff this also as I
mentioned
statisticians have been studying the
species in the context of course
something called correspondence analysis
that's where I bring that terminology
from you can think about correspondence
analysis as the ugly sibling of
principal component analysis it's but
you look at it there also there's a
fantastic paper by Buju and also a
method proposed by Bremen and Friedman
called alternating conditional
expectations that seeks you estimate the
largest principal inertia component and
if you want to see some of these
references I will refer you to a recent
transactions papers that we had from a
couple of years ago so and our
contribution is what I'm bringing to the
table here today is that we're applying
the picu obtain an estimation through a
tacit view of privacy so let's go back
to privacy okay and now before we had
something that looked like the
information bottleneck review so much
information bottleneck and what we're
going to look now is that the estimation
bottleneck right measuring the
dependence between X and Y and s and Y
in terms of chi-square okay this is an F
divergence so the region of achievable
pair and just before I say that let me
just refresh your memory so s will be a
sensitive attribute X is your data P of
s X is fixed and we're trying to
understand the limits of designing the
mapping from X to Y for disclosing data
so the chi-square is a divergence that
also satisfies the data processing
inequality the set of achievable pairs
will also live in this blue set here
below the 45-degree line and what I'm
going to present next is a proof in
pictures of a theorem which is a sharper
lower bound for something that we call
the estimation funnel which is the
counterpart of the privacy funnel ok so
just bear with me on this so here's the
picture right so we have we have the
Joint Distribution between s and X is
fixed we can look at the P I see the
composition of the Joint Distribution
between s and X right and when you do
that decomposition what you end up with
is with a set of basis functions of s
and through the conditional expectation
operator right there transformed to
these functions of X where each function
corresponds to the MMSE estimator of
in this species here so if you ask me
given an observation of X what is the
function that you can reconstruct with
the smallest mean square error without
the 0 mean unit variance function that
will be F 1 here right and the error
will be 1 minus the largest by super
principle inertia component what is the
hardest function in terms of MMSE that
will be FD here and that corresponds to
the smallest principal inertia component
now our engineering goal wish you
understand how to design this blue box
here this privacy mapping right so f of
your mayor vision in both privacy and
utility in terms of Chi square
intuitively you want to design this
mapping such that when you observe Y the
only function of X that you can reliably
reconstruct in a mean squared error
sense is the one that's aligned with G
of D here which in turn is the MMSE
estimator of the function that you can
least reliably reconstruct from X so if
you're only revealing a little bit of
information about X or Y you would want
to review it in this direction here this
doesn't mean that you're revealing G of
D that means that you're designing a
random atomization mechanism you're
designing this randomized mapping so
that if you observe y only G of D can be
reliably inferred we don't know if we
can do that exactly hence it's a lower
bound but this gives us the first part
of the lower bound of the region for the
estimation for the privacy funnel now
let's assume that you're walking here
and you really send a little bit more
information about X through Y the second
direction that you're going to reveal
this information is a one that's aligned
to the second hardest function to
estimate in an MSc sense F D minus 1 you
would like to review why in such a way
that given observation of Y the only
functions of X that you can estimate
reliably as in this true dimensional
subspace given by G of D and G of D
minus 1 again we don't know if you can
design such a mapping but we can show
that this is the best that you could do
in theory and so lower bounding that
gives me the second part of this region
and as you proceed like that you get the
remaining lower bound information to all
the Chi square distance between s and y
coming to picture
here that's obviously constrained right
if I just want to minimize the inference
of yeah just why it's yes oh no it comes
here where we're trying to release any
some amount of chi-square information
between x and y while minimizing the
chi-square information is constraint yes
exactly so this is linear or is it just
the lower bound this piecewise linear
yeah so the exciting part about this
well at least the part I get excited
about is a very beginning of this of
this lower bound right because if you
can show that this small SPI C is 0 it
means that I can walk in this plateau
here without like releasing any
information about Y so that means that I
can release some information about X
through why we're keeping s and y
perfectly independent because Chi square
of s and Y being 0 implies perfect
independence then I know at least in
some basis that's what exactly well yeah
if you could learn this that says like
that and this is an if and only if
statement which and gives you the funda
meses area sufficient condition for
perfect privacy when can I reveal some
information about X while keeping s
perfectly private and that's given by
the smallest Prince partnership
component
and you can flip this argument around
then you'll get the also a piecewise
upper bound for the same region just
using this kind of like water list kind
of like filling out the singular values
approach and for something that we call
the estimation bottleneck okay so I
think I still have time to go through
this now I'm going to talk a little bit
how can you use this to actually design
privacy of training mappings I'm going
to give one way of doing it in the case
you know the distribution right you can
actually build this as a convex
formulation and I'm going to illustrate
this through a question that I asked the
other attendees of this symposium right
here which is how can a random verb if
you give me a random variable X how can
it be perturbed in order to hide a
single function of X f of X right so
let's seem that s is a function of X how
can you design this mapping produce a
wire perturbation of X so that that
single function is hidden and based on
what we saw under principal components
you can see that that probably will play
a role here so just as a warm-up just as
a quick warm-up let's look at a model
that all of us know and love which is
the one-time pad
okay so one-time pad of course and then
now assume that X is actually a whole
sequence of bits X event if you're
disclosing Y event and you're you're
restricting your privacy mechanism
should be additive in this way okay so
I'm just gonna XOR it with the key for
example so assume that my tear short
right so instead of hiding the whole
message I can't and mikey has entropy
smaller than the input of the channel so
I can't hide the whole message but can
we information theoretically hide
certain classes of functions right like
regardless of the computational power of
an adversary right even mr. Sharkey of
course information will be leaking
obviously but maybe some things will be
information theoretic lis hidden and
this will get beat this will this
exercise of service of warm-up for a
more general formulation so just just
bear with me on this so in this case if
you assume that X is binary we are going
to write binary as minus 1 and 1 we know
they're from free analysis of boolean
functions
it's amazing book by Ryan O'Donnell on
that that we can decompose any real
function of X in terms of a big
is this basis is given by the parity
bits of the of the inputs and these
rules here are just like you can think
about those as the alphas we had before
these are just the weights in terms of
the composing your your function this is
a fact that you can do that for any
boolean function in this case when X is
uniformly distributed it turns out that
if X is uniformly distributed and your
channel is a BSc so this key is just
your it's just bit flips where you flip
a certain bit of probability epsilon the
left and right principle functions in
this case are exactly these parity bits
note that here the entropy of the key
can be much much smaller than the
entropy of the message of X of n of the
input but the question that we ask is
given yn how well can we guess or infer
the parity bits right and it turns out
that for this vanilla binary symmetric
channel the binary symmetric channel
acts almost like a low-pass filter right
so you from the output of a binary
symmetric channel you can reliably
estimate parity bits of low order
interactions so the each individual bit
you can infer them pretty well but if
you ask me the XOR of the whole sequence
you have a hard time guessing that and
specifically if you define a function
Kiev s of X of n as a the parity bit of
a set call of s how well you can guess a
bit from the output of binary symmetric
channel decays exponentially with the
number of entries in that input so the
takeaway here is that the the binary
symmetric channel acts almost like a
low-pass filter and when the case where
X is uniform we can generalize this
analysis for any distribution of
additive noise here the left and right
principle functions are exactly the
parity bits you can def compose any
function unit variance function in terms
of a weighted sum of these parity bits
and you can write the MMSE of estimating
this function this this really nicely as
1 minus the sum of alpha squared there's
an estimation here times this expected
value where you might recognize this is
simply the Hadamard
the principal functions in disk the
principal
your components in this case are simply
the result of the Hadamard transform of
the noise I know there's a lot to unpack
here but what I want to take take away
from this is that well if we want to
hide certain functions of the input I
could potentially tailor this noise in
such a way that the they hear exactly
the the attenuate exactly the values of
the components where the where my
function the values off of s of the
function that I want to hide is high so
again let me restate this all that I'm
saying is that well if you want to
design this mapping out your hide
certain functions I can tailor this
noise in terms of how I do compose my
function in terms of these parity bits
how can we generalize this you can
actually generalize this by building a
convex optimization problem so this is
the set up that I'm I'm going to restate
the same thing now in a slightly more
generality we return to our privacy
setup right so s is our secret private
future X's our data we're going to
assume that what I want to hide is a set
of functions of X denoted by s 1 to s m
and I'm going to restrict the MMSE of
estimating each one of these functions
to be at at it should be larger than
theta I so that these values are pretty
high yeah I'm gonna go a little bit
quicker over this and this is something
that looks like utility right so I give
I give you a set of functions you can
think about these as G has good
functions of X very much review I want
uniformly bound the largest
reconstruction error by Delta you can
find think about other variations about
this and just to make everything nice
and convex some when I'm designing this
mapping I'm going to be restrict X you
have the same distribution as Y this
allows us to formulate that as a convex
optimization problem and then the goal
is should try to design this map in P of
Y given X that there's something like
this right so if you have the subspace
of functions that are good that you want
to infer given X and the subspace of
functions that are bad the circuit
functions much is somehow design this
mapping so you attenuate right the space
of bad functions secret functions
you can already see that if the space
spanned by private functions and the
space spanned by useful functions are
somewhat orthogonal you will have a
favorable trade-off between privacy and
utility in practice that's not
necessarily the case what's gonna happen
is something like this when you design
that mapping you're going to be
increasing the MMSE of estimating both
the secret and the private functions
because there may be correlations
between them and yeah and you can try to
navigate this trade-off space under
these restrictions by formulating an
optimization problem I'm not gonna go
into the details I refer you to our
latest paper it's on archive on how to
do this believe me this is a convex
optimization problem if you knew the the
distribution of the data you can plug it
in and solve it we have some numerical
examples on that but hopefully this just
gives you gives you a flavor of how you
can use this interpretation of the
principal components to do this kind of
subspace alignment and design these
mappings so I'm going to conclude just
talking a little bit about in practice
how can you estimate these principal
components from data right for
especially very large data sets I'm
going to just for 30 seconds go over
this part what do we have in order to
design these that use SBIC based convex
program you have something that looks
like convex Aware context-aware privacy
where you have a reference data set you
can estimate the FS given X you have
your utility privacy constraints you
plug it into this convex optimization
problem it give it your convex solver
and it will give your privacy assuring
mapping and as you sample no samples
from P of X you pass it through that
locally through that mapping and reveal
the sanitized Y of course since the
reference dataset has finite samples you
might ask well your privacy and utility
guarantees might not match from trained
test time so what is the relation
between the number of samples and this
reference dataset and the guarantees
that you can provide here well this is
one one result on this lalita will be
presenting
in the next talk I think a lot more
about how these trade-offs work so I'm
not going to talk about that no no what
I want you to talk about is how can we
estimate the P I see is over large data
sets so this is something I'm
particularly exciting about so just bear
with me at the end so how can you
estimate these prints printers your
components right well there is one
method of doing it I already mention
about it called correspondence analysis
this is a method in statistics where you
Bill if everything is nice and discrete
you build this contingency table you
normalize it and you take its singular
value decomposition and you find the
principal functions there are a few
limitations for this approach first it
requires categorical data and it does
not really scale for a large alphabet so
these matrices will be really really
really large and there are other methods
such as the ace method that run into
similar problems so let's say that x and
y or continuous or x is an image or
something like that how can you scale
this up to meet the principal components
in order to do that you have to go back
through the basics remember that we saw
that the P ICS are actually the solution
of this problem of maximizing
correlation right they're the natural
solution of this problem where you're
trying to maximize the correlation
between F and X and the problem of
solving this up is so just if now's a
good time to pay attention if you're
kind of if you if I lost you at one
point but the problem of solving so get
back in the game so the problem of
solving this maximization is challenging
because you're maximizing over all
possible real functions of x and y right
you're searching over this large space
of functions however you could be able
to approach this as long as you could
you could index these functions and
search over a large enough space and
fortunately like commodity already
hinted over the last few years we have
very efficient methods of searching over
large spaces of functions via neural
networks all right so when I think about
a neural network when I think about the
output of a neuron of a neural network I
think about that as a point right
because that little neuron is nothing
more than a point in the space of finite
variance functions of the input right so
that's what Dan your own represents
right and as long as it has finite
variance and which for all practical
purposes we can assume that is the case
so we can index the functions of finite
variance some functions of X through a
neural network do the same thing with Y
and as long as we can cleverly design a
loss function that we can back propagate
on and maximizes this correlation we
might be able to recover the P ICS and
we actually did that this is the the
loss function that we back propagate on
it's something that also appeared in a
paper called deep canonical correlation
analysis even though the authors didn't
connect it to this theoretical machinery
that we're mentioning here and I just
want to give you a flavor of how this
looks on actual data so this is
something that looks complicated it's
estimating correlations over batches of
your training data but you can't back
propagate this on tensorflow
so you can actually fit your own metrics
to do that let's see how this works so
when x and y are jointly Gaussian your
principal functions or your neighborhood
friends the hermite polynomials and you
can actually feed the two to neural
networks jointly Gaussian random
variables train them and see that the
output of these neural networks after
you normalize it actually correspond to
the true that her meet polynomials and
this approximation becomes increasingly
worse as you go to higher degrees
because the BICS becomes smaller and
smaller you can repeat the same exercise
using a uniform bits this is something
when you when you go higher order
polynomials in your basis so when you
when you when x and y are binary or or
bits that we looked at the binary
symmetric channel case earlier I
mentioned that the principal functions
or the parity bits you can also see that
in this case the U you approximately
recover the parity bits here and it's
interesting because you can feed x and y
through a binary symmetric channel with
cross over probably 2.1 and it finds
these associations and you can change
the bit and finds associations as well
and the cool thing is that now we can
use this statistical technique called
correspondence analysis at a scale that
I think it hadn't been done before
right so correspondence analysis what it
saw to do is sum
that looks like nonlinear PCA so you
would find these principal functions
right this gives you nonlinear
dimensions of X and you will get samples
from your data set X and plot it
according to these orthogonal directions
then you will get samples of Y and put
on the same plot the orthogonal
directions you one of Y and G to apply
and plot them together and try to find
correlations between them and before
most considering this is that's one of
the applications of Correspondence
analysis but these are nonlinear
transformations right and unlike our HJs
you don't have to appear I choose a
kernel here you just train her neural
networks we can do that with fairly
large data sets this is one example with
I don't think you can read it properly
but this is the cow go food competition
data set from Yummie these are 50
thousand recipes their written
correspondence analysis on and here
cuisine is X coziness Y and X are your
ingredients or your recipes and you can
plot them together in the same plot and
you can see that over here in this
corner you can't read it but you have
agent coziness together here you have
European cuisines Mexican is down here I
and you can see associations between
like for example soy and sesame they're
close to to the Asian cuisines brazilian
cuisine is right in the middle so that
was something that I'm Brazilian so I
was pretty pleased with that we recently
have had a paper on at the new reps
workshop on machine learning for the
developing world where we applied this
this tool to analyze the expenditure of
Brazilian congressmen so Brazil has a
surprisingly good has a very good open
data program but where you can go back
to 2009 and see all the expense reports
from the congressman how they're using
their discretionary funds and you can
plot that in analyze it using
correspondence analysis and since I
think this has been recorded that's the
last thing I'm going to say about that
and just to show that you can use this
do this at a much larger scale we have
results with cipher stan and cipher 100
and your image sets that usually care
about of course here correspondence
analysis doesn't really reveal
a lot of intuition but at least just to
show that this method skills one of the
overlapping features in these images
right well the problem here like why are
your labels so when you will end up just
doing a classification as usual but is
this is just to show that yeah you can
use this in data sets of the size that
you care about so that's what we're
working on now like so that's a question
of how can we then this is not privacy
yet like hopefully what we're trying to
work on now is to get this and feed it
back to privacy and then these
intuitions that we have from the
information theory and from these
optimization problems that filling
subspaces and now we can estimate these
things how can we know that's just pure
this is just pure data analytics so I'm
gonna conclude with the same side I
finished yesterday but the big data
comes big responsibility a little bit
cheesy but I do get the of information
three can help and in things like
privacy fairness and transparency
there's a lot of exciting work and a lot
of theory that we can bring to this
table so again this is just a few papers
that my group has produced over the past
couple of years and yeah I would be
happy to take questions thank you we
have a break now and then
we'll take a seven minute yes I have a
more of a general question I actually
really like this because I missed a
decision so I appreciate information but
when you do your literature search do
you ever actually look into statistical
literature on on data confidentiality
made of privacy even though we have
shifted and many of the methods were not
formal the ideas that you are talking
about here have been explored in
statistical disclosure limitation
literature and I often don't see any of
that stuff referenced in CS papers or
information time and just curious as to
are you not finding these papers or is
it that that somehow it doesn't relate
so you feel or what is it that it's
missing so I can give you an answer for
that I'm always searching for those
papers like for example I I can tell you
my experience in working with these
quantities that principal components
like because this is something that I
came across it in the more course like
correspondence analysis literature and
then learned that like information
theorists had studied them all Brittany
had studied them and so on and I realize
that statisticians such as indras Vajra
and so on add them phenomenal work on
that but these things these works don't
reference each other and they appeared
over the space of several decades so
that's something that we're always
trying to be as careful as possible if
you think there's any references that
are missing please that you know I would
be happy to
[Music]
general statistical literature there
they are the happy paper and statistical
disclosure of vacation
for example they use this idea of
dimension reduction in a way or there is
paper on while back I think the
methodology was called wrong ro and I'm
friendly base matrix something I can't
remember where they basically are
looking at exactly like zero mean and
variance you're looking at the principal
components and you're trying to break
down
we're they looking at the spectrum of
the conditional expectation operator
does look at and I wanted to mention
resources of America maybe they were
aware of this there's a paper by Terry
at rotini and Feinberg while back where
they actually looked at the Bayesian
perspective or thinking about what are
the limits of the adversary and and
looking at these basically conditional
type distributions and and and the
limits and some some literature related
to this and there should be many more
other papers but I mean I I can't
remember all of it I'm happy to take a
look at absolutely we should have
definitely chat I think like what I
think there's a lot of love not only
here and I love it is it even
some things that family is talking about
but it seems that we are yes this is
being criticized often for not being
formal enough but it seems it's some of
the ideas that were initially introduced
even if if you formally let's say are
being kind of completely ignored right
and some some of the ideas were there no
absolutely you know I I mean if you have
a set of references I would love to look
sure absolutely
okay my problem has been I do try to
find them but because these are my kind
of disjoint therefore it's hard to find
them to for my friend sess and I really
apologize it is you know yeah if you
tell me I will read them or ever made
you submit them and III Kosar absolutely
like something we are always striving
for because the language that like
computer scientists information
theorists statisticians use is like the
it's all probability and conditional
probabilities and so on but and so a lot
of these ideas appear in different forms
and all these different fields and we
absolutely want you be as fair as
possible sighting and so do send them
the boundaries and you know I don't read
again I don't remember although there's
a lot of concept and thinking about of
boundaries even thinking about it
geometrically that said that literature
also III know it's not as obvious as
easy not to say that you know such
decisions as well often like we miss a
lot of other element literature when we
work on stuff so this is this is not
directed one way I just yeah absolutely
I think we spin and I know Mike my
graduate students as well probably a lot
of people here have the same experience
that you spend a lot of time trying to
find the right combination of keywords
that you put on a Google Scholar search
just say and sometimes we miss stuff and
absolutely it'll bit if you know if you
have anything please do send it to us
because we would absolutely include
actually yeah that would be fantastic
yeah and again some of them that we do
miss more of a formal treatment but this
said even even perhaps the credit or
someone or maybe you will be you will
find some of the ideas relevant and
interesting and you can follow -
absolutely and I think absolutely thank
you so much for that Thanks and maybe
any other questions or yeah so I think
it's really cool it's it's very MMSE you
know in its formulation and I feel like
it in the end of the day like the things
that are really secret like the recess
of Plan B's are all the street waiting
examples are usually like you're going
example this like political affiliation
right so I guess it's just like comment
I guess that like you know it seems like
videos and you got something you know by
their examples and so on whatever would
they be like focusing more on like
discrete examples I think you're trying
to hide might be more applicable to like
the applications you started with
yeah yeah for sure like in when you have
one bit than mmm is probability of
correct guessing but um but yeah no
absolutely like that's but I think
that's absolutely crying no I think it's
secrets actually discreet it gets the
that's that's the key of something that
maximum week you guys leave ass there's
always a speeds you talking about
guessing that yeah I mean there are
other things and locational privacy and
so on where you know what are you the
quantity that justice is continuous but
location itself is not usually what
we're trying to protect it's like you
know some discrete quantity gets are
correlated with your location that your
elephant in China thanks it all in the
end always go back to like the street
quantities that are trying to protect me
but it raises a very interesting
question which may be wrong with you
what is the what is an upper bound on
accuracy that an adversary should learn
it should be zero that you should never
learn anything more or can you learn me
with some 20% Atticus I guess a related
question discrete is like probably err
predicting something right versus
continuous could be l1 norm where l
2-norm
predicting something yeah you might
imagine making case be either one let's
say my salary shouldn't be predicted
would help wandelaar but it's Jordan I'm
very discreetly well you could just sort
eyes it right it's all PI dollars so
it's like 20 bits left to the right of
my salary than that will pay or
something like that that's actually I
was reading a paper that was developing
that same thing like maybe it's it's all
the same maybe that was a good example
actually yeah salary or why did weights
like anyways a medical thing they don't
he just sees me on the street already
I guess maybe medical data like a blood
pressure if you're in the range I can
discriminate you on your insurance maybe
I don't want to be seen like my blood
pressure like within a certain range and
you could just pretend what pressure
that I want to hide or is there with our
diabetic or not exactly so we have you
using your high blood pressure that's
continuous but you know pre just for
Tizen saying I'm better at odds yeah
then you hide that and so that's so I
even wrongly I usin see where you want
an argument so
it is show the secrets and discreet but
a lot of the times based on the
continuous it's very hard to predict the
discrete right like you know I mean the
black Tricia diabetic is probably a good
example where you can but you know like
gender right it's based on that's the
image gender it's not easy to detect
right so I guess I mean in theory you're
absolutely right in practice
automatically figuring it out is problem
you say you know predisposition is not
so easy exact financial future sir it's
more than that sort of continuing this
idea I we have continuous data secrets
are discrete but we can't necessarily
know in advance which discreet secrets
we want to protect down the line and so
pre discretization only protects you for
the secrets you can anticipate
potentially and not for the ones you
can't and that would be an argument
against focusing really on pre
descritization meaning so let's you know
let's predict the secret based on this
continuous variable and then let me
protect that that binary variable okay
but that you know that's a great idea if
you know exactly what is the function of
the continuous data that you're
concerned about but if you don't
actually know because you don't know in
five years what people are going to be
caring about fighting you can't do it so
it's going question if I can protect all
hidden discrete quantities like the
notions and secrecy and privacy that has
historically been most successful are
ones that are like actually end up being
as independent as possible of the
structure of the thing you're trying to
hide right so you know a good example is
like if you're if you're hiding all
possible binary valued functions of some
random variable that's sort of like you
know that's some total variation style
guarantee and you can interpret it in a
continuous way or you can interpret it
as like binary things but it's somehow
like has various lots of operational
meanings and this came up in your talk
yesterday you were saying like oh well
you could consider different types of
guessing right rather than just trying
to guess the secret you try to get
something close to it or get a set of K
things and you win and you get it in
your stuff like that and any of these
lead to the same definition that's like
a very robust statement and like people
tend to we tend to gravitate overtime to
things that have that type of robustness
right so I would say like try not to
fake the structure of the secret end and
try to look for things that are as
Intendant impossible as possible partly
for the reasons that Katrina said who
knows down the line but I think you know
the setup that somebody can have like if
you're thinking about
settings where you have explicit data
user agreements and you know perhaps
there's no outside some kind of data
sharing and you know there's some
additional restrictions maybe there you
could try to think about you know in
order to perhaps gain more utility or
something like that but that's a very
very specific setting I mean I certainly
will not you know if you anticipate that
is gonna go further out at some point
right which I think if it is hard I mean
this is why DP has been the idea that
you know you're preventing it it gives
the further future attacks in a way
right so you know I mean if you can do
it with the good utility that's yeah I
think they have been as a bottom line
yeah wait god I mean yes societal norms
change but it takes about a decade or I
don't know multiple decades I mean
wouldn't happen in the museum of like a
few weeks right it's not societal norms
necessarily though you know we realize
next week
yeah the combination of these variables
lets us predict something about you that
we didn't know I mean this is their
changing very rapidly
we're talking about defining secrets
right yeah but so what what with a
sensitive data about you is gonna be
different next week when we realize that
we can infer something totally
embarrassing from three things that
currently seem innocuous I don't think
it's just about Norman I think it's
about what we know how to infer and
that's changing quickly what other
sources yeah sort of historically of how
people have tried to classify sensitive
versus non sensitive information it's
often in terms of oh well this is
sensitive because it can be linked at
his other datasets and this is non
sensitive because it doesn't exist
anywhere else or it's you know surely
it's okay or these you know whatever
kind of it's it's not that it's not that
there's always a deep engagement with
social norms when you're thinking
through like what sensitive I'm not
right I think they sort of exercises are
doomed to fail I sort of like let's
define what these are yeah secrets I
don't know I think it could be at a very
finite time and it's absolutely
absolutely mattered either you publish
or you don't publish at all
would you rather published in some
counties with them month or you're gonna
sit there and insist and ask I don't
know I mean this could be a very
critical thing I mean you know I think
it's I mean it cuz I think whenever we
talk about privacy we are implicitly
talking data release but which may not
be the case right so an example would be
you know in location privacy you are
showing somebody some ad based on their
approximate location but you know you're
not really story with
right so in that case the fact that it
will be used and linked ten years later
you know that's not right so my I don't
I mean I feel like these are all
application also comes into play right
thank you for releasing your data now
it's because you want to get something
out of it
like if and something will be correlated
with my data right so somehow that HAP's
you come into account as well is broken
it needs to be fixed and perhaps the
statement is correct on some level but
there's been some recent research that
uses things like shuffling the data
things like that using secure
aggregation some cryptographic premises
in order to collect data from people
without even knowing who's sending you
what and you only see aggregates for
instance that secret cherry increase to
move from local deep into central TP so
there is some you know process that's
kept but the point is then there is some
pre-processing needed to give a privacy
or some parrots of course I I think
somehow these pre-processing methods are
not being taken into account in the
larger context to make it to make it
seem that it's all really shouldn't be
context aware is somewhat naive because
a lot of time the tailor should tailor
it is being used to appropriately figure
where to add the privacy in any
application and so impressive in there
is then the discussion that or the data
could be really bad but I'm going to
massage it to be reasonable enough to
add privacy motions to it that are
strong enough so then there's already an
impressive pre-processing matter
something that's not being accounted for
in the end to it
so the applications coming dependability
all right thanks everyone